I I'm not the favorite person of some of
these intelligence agencies or some of
these groups that would have that vested
interest I'm sure locki doesn't like it
when I talk about that they have an an
actual spacecraft that they've been
reverse engineering they were given one
locky's locki Martin yeah it's an
aerospace company but there are others
right is is that the one where they say
they've got the the biologics the the
corpses of other worldly they just found
it in me in Mexico that little threefoot
is that what you're talking about oh
that's sorry about that no this was from
the Congress hearing so there was this
this was the sound bite that was heard
around the world where the guy the the
lady asked are you uh in possession of
any uh aircraft or you know and the guy
said well yeah we have the aircraft and
we have biologics that was my friend
David grush so he came to me first out
of concern for his sa okay so you guys
are talking about safety so let's let's
na this one for a second right um look I
am operating within my right as a free
human and a journalist and I'm doing my
best to do no harm and get information
out find it to be credible um I'm sure
there are people I know that there are
people and groups that do not like the
idea of disclosure or this idea of
transparency on the UAP or UFO issue
there are of course repercussions from
people like that you know there are uh
ways in which people make can make your
life quite UNC comtable but I've I'm
either immune or ignorant or I just
don't know when I'm in trouble half the
time so I think as long as people do
things legally and lawfully and they do
their best there's always going to be
push back and there's going to be
ramifications anyway for other people
there have been reprisals that that's a
big we so we should talk about this that
that I don't want to go too weird but
that that deepness of people trying to
harm you okay cuz that was that was said
in in in Congress was that David
personally there were actions taken
against him as a intelligence officer
but also other people they even brought
up like um you know harming people so
here's the deal this is people being
harmed by by people that want to keep
the secret okay within factions of of
agencies right that was the claim that
was made in Congress that this is a true
fact and we can he could bring forward
witnesses that are both hostile and
non-hostile mean people that want to
talk people that don't want to talk and
he's got a list you just have to have
the clearance and get a skiff so they're
working on that so here's the deal
though the whole thing is that there
were reprisals against people like David
grush to come forward he did it legally
and lawfully he went to the intelligence
community's Inspector General the
Inspector General is like the cops of
the intelligence community so it's under
whistleblower protections whistleblower
protections act it's a presidential
protection act 18 or something like or
19 basically he says this is what I know
I know that we have craft that are
nonhuman origin I know that we have
biologics or Biologicals and I know
where they are and I know who's working
on them and I've interviewed 40 people
plus that have direct hands-on
experience with these materials and
these programs and he's like put that
into a whistleblower complaint
whistleblower complaint comes back they
go we find his [__] credible and Urgent
well why why did the Inspector General
find it credible and Urgent cuz they did
their own
under oath with polygraph sometimes they
did investigation into the witnesses
that and what he found and it was his
job by the way he was tasked by um the
UAP TF which is UAP task force to look
at over 2,000 black budget programs and
try to figure out or any of these have
to do with non-human technology and he
found them what what's a black budget
program so like any program where they
don't have to Define exactly what the
money is being spent on
and you can go to like Library Congress
if you're a total nerd like me and you
can find like calculate the black budget
CU it'll say black budget and you can
say how much money that we know of is
being put into these programs they never
tell you what's in them they won't tell
Congress anybody so the whole thing is
we need oversight there's tons of money
being spent on this and there are UFO
programs there are crash retrievals
they're of craft of Unknown Origin to be
magnanimous I'll say that and there's
biological aspects to these crafts 100%
question is does our government have
oversight from some of the um
corporations that have taken some of
these in so imagine in the 50s you're
like hey locked we got something we
can't figure out we don't know what to
do just look at it try to get derivative
Technologies you know you'll benefit
from it and loi's like oh cool and they
take that take total control and people
kind of forget about it that's the
situation we're in right now so this guy
David grush came forward because of the
of the reprisals that's why he came to
me and George knap first don't report on
it he's like I just want you to know I'm
[__] scared and so famously he came
forward to us we kept his damn secret we
didn't even break the story we kept his
secret and I'll tell you it is true you
know he was uh there's a lot of things
still going on to try to shut him up
well I the reason I asked it too is this
something I've never spoken about but my
grandfather worked for Led Martin and
there was a lot of things that he was
unable to speak about this was stuff
that he had to take to his grave so I
know there's a lot of things and you
know that could be something like what
we're talking about now it could be
Weaponry we don't really know exactly
what he did CU he wasn't allowed to
speak about it but I also know someone
who's very tapped into a public figure
he's like someone who works closely with
the public figure who is an alien
activist spokesperson whatever you want
to call it and locked Martin people show
up to with this person the I can't get
into specifics about saying too much of
this person because it's not my business
to disclose but locked Martin people
show up a lot in this person's life and
um it's very interesting that they're
such a big part of this but it's so like
unspoken and they can't speak publicly
about these things yeah that's a shame
I'm the least paranoid person I know I
like I probably should be more Paradigm
it I I it's sad to hear that so look
anything done in a classified realm
you're not supposed to talk especially
if it's a special access program which
is above classified is like it's
classified a lot of people top secret
clearance in this country but if it's
special access compartmentalized special
access you have to be on that program to
even know that information so when
someone works at locked if they keep and
maintain their clearances in order to
work there they can't talk about General
stuff even like is the locked a
private um company so there's I don't
want to just focus on them in the it's
an like an aerospace or technology a
defense department uh company so locki
does its own individualized company but
its biggest contracts are with our
government right so like our government
itself doesn't like produce war planes
we hire out with aerospace companies to
do that so you got Ron Boeing locked all
these companies got it so a lot of these
companies have acquired materials I'll
say like over the decades right because
they want to figure out what here's what
they're trying to do what they're trying
to do is say we don't get what this is
but we know it can be weaponized and
we'd much rather that we weaponize this
[__] before anybody else like I don't
know say Russia China so initially the
the secrecy like the atomic program it's
so that we can have a technological
advantage in Warfare because that's the
only thing that really keeps us and
distinguishes us is how big bombs we
have and how we can Implement them or
our our Tech you know that's it it's
Warfare so I get it I get why they were
keeping the big secret for a long time
but cats out of the [__] bag and it's
coming out of the bag even more now and
they see the writing on the wall so what
are they going to do
you can't admit to everything but you
can say like the atomic program okay
we're tinkering with the atom now we're
not going to teach you to make a bomb
but we're tinkering with the atom same
thing with UFOs fess
up all right and so people like like uh
well what was that group that meets up
aib atib atip and oap so ASAP was the
mother program and atip was the
auxiliary program off of AA and these
are all the the heads of certain places
that
meet up like like billionaires and they
talk about UFO [__] no no so that's
different maybe you're talking about
something else but so a okay um who who
owned uh Skinwalker Ranch oh that was
Robert Bigalow so Robert Bigalow would
meet up with a bunch of other people and
they would discuss it's a secret meeting
or whatever but well kind of there
there's a lot in so that was called bass
so I'll break it down like how I
understand it for like 101 style which
is that you've got people bidding on
this contract to study UFOs and Bigalow
was positioned well they retrofitted
Bigalow Aerospace to be able to have the
clearance the classified you know
clearance of retaining materials like a
spacecraft so like a Lockheed Martin
type totally but more nuanced and that
it was really this whole thing was about
UFOs he already had big low Aerospace
put Inflatables up you know attach them
to the International Space Station cool
interesting billionaire guy right but
really what they were doing was they
were like there's $22 million and so
Senator Harry Reid put this in motion
and he got this secret black budget $22
million which is like not even the cost
of one of our planes but okay and
they're like we want to do a a
technology UFO program that was the core
of it right so Bigalow say cool I will
create something called bass big
Advanced Aerospace space studies or
something like that we'll absorb that
income and we will get our facilities
ready to receive materials you know or
materials that they find like a craft
you know that was the the you know the
idea I think behind it and we'll do all
these studies get the best scientists on
this so they did that and it was under a
program in the defense intelligence
agency called
AAP and uh ASAP stands for
um aw Advanced weapon systems you know
what my brain right now it's a [__]
acronym this is the the main UFO program
that absorbed the $22 million
right then you've heard about a tip a
tip was reported on in the New York
Times when the public kind of found out
about this so George nap had known about
it since the beginning but he's not the
New York Times that Harry Reed called
him said please don't report this let
the New York Times break it and he's
like all right New York Times broke the
story about
atip Advanced Aerospace threat
identification program there a guy named
Lou alzando Who you might have heard of
who is the guy that that led that
endeavor in that effort they weren't the
recipient of the 22 million that was
misreporting by the New York Times but a
tip they took the military cases and
they took everything that AAP when it
was ending and they took that and they
ran with it so it's very heroic to
continue this study so Lou alzando is is
a hero in my eyes that he took this and
kept going with it you know for our
military and intelligence communities so
that's the breakdown of what you learn
2017 changed the world that's when that
New York Times article came out that you
probably heard about that [__] black
budget whatever New York Times 17 that
told the world that the government was
studying UFOs secretly and before that
we were told nothing to see here move on
we ended studying UFOs in 1969 with
project boook there's no such thing but
then 2017 we find out oh yeah they're
real [__] interested do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want to
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude